- [Voiceover] In the last
video we introduced you to
the derivative property right over here
that if my function is
equal to some constant
that the derivative is going to be zero
at any X, and we made a graphical argument
and we also used the
definition of the limits
to feel good about that.
Now let's give a few
more of these properties
and these are core properties as you
throughout the rest of your calculus life
your career, you will be
using some combination
of these properties to find derivatives.
So it's good to, one, know about them,
and to feel good that
they're actually true.
The second one is if my function F of X
is equal to some constant
times another function G of X
well, then the derivative
of F of X is going to be equal
to that same constant.
Let me do it, that same constant
times the derivative of the G of X.
And once again, maybe
we can make a actually
we could make a graphical
argument for why that is true.
This is going to multiply the slope
is one way to think about it.
But it's easier to make
an algebraic argument
just using, frankly we can
use either one of these
definitions of the derivative.
I'll use the one on the right
because it feels more general
although you can say,
well this is true for A,
but X could be any A.
But I'll just use the one on the right.
So, if we want to find F prime of X,
F prime of X using this definition,
we know, we know.
F prime of X is going
to be equal to the limit
as X, I'm sorry, as H approaches zero.
I'm using that definition.
Of F of X plus H
minus F of X
all of that over H.
Well, what is F of X plus H?
This is the limit
as H approaches zero.
F of X plus H is
K times G of X plus H.
Minus F of X,
well that's just KG of X.
KG of X.
All of that over
H.
And then you can factor the K out.
This is going to be equal to the limit
as H approaches zero of K
times G of X plus H
minus G of X
all of that over H.
All I did was factor that K out.
And we know from our limit properties
that this is the same thing as K
times the limit as H approaches zero
of G of X plus H minus
G of X, all of that over H.
And of course, all of this
business right over there.
That is just G prime of X.
So, this is equal to K
times G prime of X.
And I know what you might be thinking.
Whoa, hey this feels like it was probably
going to be true, so I
just assumed it was true.
But you can't just assume that.
I don't know, sometimes you can
when you're first trying
to get your head around it
you can say, oh, this seems
like a reasonable thing.
But in math, we like to
really know that it is true
otherwise we will build all sorts of
conclusions based on unsound foundations.
This allows us to ensure
that this is something
that we can do.
So, this is, it's good
to go through what might feel like
a little bit of work to
get to this conclusion.
Now let's do the third property.
The third property
is the idea
that if I have some function
that's the sum or the difference of
two other functions,
so G of X, and let's see,
I'm using H a lot so,
H, let's say,
I don't know, J of X.
J, yeah sure, why not, J of X.
You don't see a lot of J of X's out there.
Well then, well then,
F prime of X
is going to be equal to
G prime of X
plus J prime of X.
And this would also have been true
if this is, instead of
it being a positive here,
if this was a negative.
Instead of addition, if
this was subtraction.
If the sum were a
difference of two functions
then your derivative is gonna be the sum
or the difference of their derivatives.
And once again, we can
just go to the definition
of F prime of X.
So, F prime of X
is going to be equal to the limit
as H approaches zero
of F of X plus H.
But what is F of X plus H?
Well, that's G of X plus H
plus J of X plus H.
So that's F of X plus H
minus F of X.
So F of X is G of X.
G of X plus J of X
plus J of X.
Notice, this is F of X plus H
minus F of X
and we're gonna put all of that over H.
So we can put all of that
all of that over H.
Well, what is that equal to?
Well, we could just rearrange what we see
on top here.
This is equal to
the limit
as H approaches zero.
Well let's see, all the mentions of G of X
I'm gonna put up front.
So G of X plus H
minus G of X.
Plus J of X plus H
minus J of X.
And then all of that, I could write it
as this, all of that over H.
Or, I could, that's the same thing as
this over H
plus that over H.
And once again,
we know from our limit properties
that that is the exact same thing as
the limit as H approaches zero,
of G of X plus H
minus G of X
all of that over H
plus the limit as H approaches zero
of J of X plus H
minus J of X
all of that over H.
And this, right over here,
that is the definition of
G prime of X.
And this right over here is
J prime, J prime of X
and we're done.
And this, instead of a positive,
this was instead of addition
this was subtraction.
Well then that subtraction
would carry through
and then instead of addition here
we would have subtraction.
So hopefully this makes you feel good
about these properties.
The properties themselves
are somewhat straightforward.
You could probably guess at them.
But it's nice to use the definition
of our derivatives to actually
feel that they are very
good conclusions to make.